♪
>> SO HOW CAN YOU SAY THAT’S NOT
A CRISIS?
>> IT DOESN’T MATTER WHAT YOU
CALL IT, IT IS AN ENORMOUS
CHALLENGE, IT IS SOMETHING THAT
IS FRONT AND CENTER FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
WILL: THE WHITE HOUSE REFUSES TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE CRISIS ON OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
GOP MEMBERS, THOUGH, OF CONGRESS
ARE TAKING IT UPON THEMSELVES TO
SEE AS WHAT IS ACTUALLY
HAPPENING WITH A DELEGATION SET
TO VISIT TEXAS ON MONDAY.
JEDEDIAH: OUR NEXT GUEST IS PART
OF THAT DELL DIVISION, FLORIDA
GOH CONGRESSMAN CARLOS JIMENEZ.
CONGRESSMAN, TELL US WHY YOU’RE
HEADED TO THE BORDER ON MONDAY.
>> WELL, WE’RE A HEADING TO THE
BORDER TO SEE FOR OURSELVES
WHAT’S GOING ON AND ALSO TO TALK
TO OUR FEDERAL AGENTS TO GET A
BETTER IDEA OF WHAT ACTUALLY IS
HAPPENING.
WE THINK THAT THERE IS A CRISIS
IS AT THE BORDER OF JOE BIDEN,
PRESIDENT BIDEN’S A MAKING, YOU
KNOW?
MY FELLOW REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUE
CALLED IT DISORDER AT THE BORDER
CUE TO EXECUTIVE ORDER, AND --
DUE TO EXECUTIVE ORDER, AND I
THINK HE IS RIGHT.
THIS WAS A CRISIS THAT DIDN’T
HAVE TO HAPPEN CREATED BE BY THE
ADMINISTRATION, THEIR RHETORIC,
THEIR POLICY, THEIR PROPOSED
LEGISLATION, ALL OF IT IS
CAUSING THIS CRISIS AT THE
BORDER.
PETE: CONGRESSMAN, WHAT ARE YOU
LOOKING FOR THE MOST?
MY APOLOGIES, BY THE WAY, FOR MY
NORWEGIAN-SOUNDING PRONUNCIATION
OF YOUR NAME.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THAT’S OKAY.
PETE: WHAT ARE YOU FOCUSED ON AS
FAR AS WHAT’S HAPPENING THERE?
>> WE NEED TO TALK TO THE
FEDERAL AGENTS AND ALSO LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT OF WHAT IS
ACTUALLY HAPPENING, HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE CROSSING.
>> WE ALREADY HAVE SOME NUMBERS
THAT SAY THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
BEING APPREHENDED HAS ALMOST
TRIPLED FROM THE SAME TIME
PERIOD LAST YEAR.
NUMBER OF FAMILY UNITS THAT HAVE
BEEN ENCOUNTERED WENT UP FROM
1,000 A MONTH TO 6,000 NOW IN
FEBRUARY.
AND IT’S JUST GOING TO GET
WORSE.
AND IT DOESN’T MATTER THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SAYS DON’T
COME NOW.
WELL, WHEN ARE WE GOING TO COME?
IF I MEAN, THEY SHOULD SAY DON’T
COME EVER, DON’T BREAK THE LAW.
THEY SHOULD HAVE NEVER
REINSTITUTED CATCH AND RELEASE,
THEY SHOULD HAVE NEVER BROKEN
THE AGREEMENTS THAT THEY HAD
WITH MEXICO AND OTHER CENTRAL
AMERICAN COUNTRIES THAT WERE
KEEPING THIS, YOU KNOW,
SITUATION MANAGEABLE.
AGAIN, A CRISIS OF THEIR OWN
MAKING, UNNECESSARY CRISIS
PUTTING AMERICANS’ LIVES IN
DANGER BUT ALSO PUTTING THE
MIGRANTS’ LIVES IN DANGER.
ONE OF THE FEW THINGS THAT
PEOPLE DON’T UNDERSTAND IS
MIGRANTS LOSE THEIR LIVES COMING
HERE.
LAST YEAR, 2019 WHICH IS THE
LAST TIME WE HAVE SOME STATS,
300 MIGRANTS AT THE BORDER, YOU
KNOW, LOST THEIR LIVES.
WE DON’T KNOW HOW MANY MORE
COUNTLESS LOSE THEIR LIVES ON
THE TRIP.
AND ALSO THE EFFECTS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING ESPECIALLY ON YOUNG
GIRLS, WE HAVE SOME STATS THAT
SAY ABOUT 30%, ABOUT ONE IN
THREE ARE RAPED DURING THIS
TRANSITION.
ALL OF THIS IS A HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS.
A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS, AGAIN, OF
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION’S OWN
CREATION.
WILL: WELL, CONGRESSMAN, WE WISH
YOU LUCK ON YOUR TRIP.
WE’D LOVE TO TALK TO YOU WHEN